als anführer der unfreien welt so
präsentiert sich china heute bei den
olympischen winterspielen die und putin
ein gipfel der autokraten der westen
schickt sportler und schaut betreten
beck
2008 war mit olympia in peking noch
hoffnung verbunden dass sich das große
china weiter öffnet wenn schon nicht für
die westliche demokratie dann immerhin
für weltweiten handel wandel für
austausch 14 jahre später hat sich china
gewandelt aber nicht zum partner sondern
zum rivalen die aufstrebende supermacht
beansprucht nach außen in asien und
sogar weltweit führung nach innen wird
absolute gefolgschaft verlangt die
demokratiebewegung von hongkong
zerschlagen die uigurische minderheit in
china unterdrückt in kunst literatur
presse kein platz mehr für opposition
die olympischen werte sind ursprünglich
andere friedlicher wettbewerb vielfalt
fair play sportsgeist das kann völker
verbinden aus freude am sport übertragen
wir diese spiele auch in peking werden
sich sportlerinnen und sportler aus
aller welt aneinander messen doch viele
schattenseiten trüben die perfekten
bilder
menschenrechtsverletzungen umweltsünden
zensur
deutschland war heute auf der
ehrentribüne nicht vertreten ohne sich
zu einem diplomatischen boykott zu
bekennen zu viele arbeitsplätze in der
automobil maschinenbau oder
chemieindustrie hängen direkt an
deutschlands wichtigstem handelspartner
scholz und bernburg schweigen vieldeutig
auch die neue regierung übt sich
gegenüber china in realpolitik
niemand will sportlern und zuschauern
den spaß verderben aber wir müssen auf
den gastgeber schauen ein politisch
gleichgeschaltet es nationalistisches
seit corona fast gänzlich abgeschottetes
china das ioc unter dem deutschen thomas
bach bietet einem autoritären regime
eine glanzvolle bühne der behauptet
diese spiele sein und politisch der lügt
[Musik]